hey schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live mitten in der nacht zum sonntag
stirbt auf einer straße bei moskau die
29-jährige da ja du ihn durch eine
autobombe
sie ist die tochter von alexander dugin
einem bekannten russischen
rechtsnationalisten und die diesen
positionen stand sie auch nach beider
beide tochter und vater verteidigten
immer zu den russischen angriffskrieg in
der ukraine
jetzt ist sie tot und es gibt viele
fragen mit denen wir uns heute in dieser
sendung beschäftigen bombenanschlag in
moskau das ist unser thema wer steckt
dahinter und es ist noch ein bisschen
komplizierter denn heute meldet sich
russland und gibt der ukraine die schuld
obwohl es ein bekenner statement gibt
von einer russischen gruppierung auch
das wird also heute bei uns thema sein
gibt es wirklich eine untergrund gruppe
die das russische system jetzt angreift
oder will russland der ukraine die
schuld für diesen anschlag geben ihr
merkt dass es ganz schön kompliziert
aber trotzdem wir versuchen das jetzt in
dieser sendung zu klären was wir wissen
was wir nicht wissen und ihr könnt
fragen stellen an die mailadresse die
viele von euch schon kennen oder direkt
in den stream und wir möchten das thema
für euch klären mit nico lange er
arbeitete mehrere jahre in der ukraine
und in russland in kiew war für die
konrad adenauer stiftung und er kennt
sich aus mit sicherheitspolitischen
fragen hallo schönen guten abend herr
lange morgen herr lange wir fangen mal
von vorne an am besten bei diesem thema
würde ich sagen da ja dugena und oder
ihr vater das war ja die ganze zeit
heute schon in der diskussion wem galt
eigentlich dieser anschlag weiß man da
schon mehr
das kann man zum jetzigen zeitpunkt noch
nicht sagen
das auto gehörte dem vater und offenbar
war es so dass beide also auch der vater
hätten in diesem auto sein sollen er hat
sich kurzfristig anders entschieden
gleichzeitig muss man aber sagen frau
dorena war nicht nur die tochter von
herrn dougan sie war selbst auch eine
rechte nationalistische
propagandisten sehr viel russischen
medien unterwegs mit sehr harter
agitation insofern könnten auch beide
dass es hier gewesen sein
und jetzt haben wir schon darüber
gesprochen werde es jetzt auch gerade
hier gesehen in der region eben ihn und
jetzt auch gerade neben mir wir sehen
das auto frack und wir haben auch da ja
dugena dort gesehen aber jetzt gibt es
natürlich noch mehr fragen was kann
damit bezweckt worden sein was könnte
dieser anschlag zu bedeuten haben es
gibt verschiedenste theorien fangen sie
bitte damit man für uns an das
aufzudröseln was könnte da wirklich
dahinter stecken
das ist wirklich zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
sehr schwer zu sagen was wirklich
dahintersteckt und gleichzeitig gibt es
eine ganze reihe von theorien die
plausibel sein könnten jetzt haben heute
die russischen behörden ja schon sehr
sicher behauptet sie wüssten es wäre die
ukraine gewesen und haben auch
angebliche belege dafür vorgebracht ich
persönlich halte das für die
unwahrscheinlichste möglichkeit eine
weitere möglichkeit ist es gab diese
erklärung ist bekennerschreiben einer
neuen gewalttätigen widerstandsgruppe
aus russland
das wäre auf jeden fall bemerkenswert
wenn es im heutigen russland diese art
von gewaltsamen widerstand gibt
insbesondere mit einem anschlag im
stadtzentrum von moskau in der nähe der
rubrik straße das ist eine sehr bekannte
straße in moskau in der sehr viele
prominente auch putin mit medien viele
wirtschaftsbosse leben also eigentlich
eine sehr sichere gegend wäre auf jeden
fall neu und bemerkenswert wenn eine
widerstandsgruppe dort einen anschlag
verüben könnte das ist die zweite
möglichkeit die dritte möglichkeit ist
frau du ihn und herr dougan unterstützen
ja nicht nur den krieg russlands gegen
die ukraine sondern sie sind ja
antreiber sie sind antreiber von rechts
die gehirn zu nationalistischen
radikalen strömungen in russland denn
das im grunde noch nicht weit genug die
nicht zufrieden sind mit diesem krieg
der läuft aus ihrer sicht schlecht sie
wollen das nicht nur eine spezial
reparation stattfindet sondern ein
richtiger krieg und von diesen gruppen
von rechts aussen sieht putin sich unter
druck und es könnte also auch eine
verdeckte aktion sein um in diese
richtung ein signal zu senden und die
macht von putin abzusichern und die
vierte möglichkeit
die auch derzeit viel diskutiert wird
ist dass dieser anschlag erzeugt wurde
von russischen behörden oder von teilen
der behörden um einen vorwand zu liefern
für noch härteres durchgreifen im innern
für noch härtere maßnahmen gegen jeden
der putin und den krieg kritisiert man
muss ja sehen das passiert vor einem
hintergrund wo es tatsächlich widerstand
gibt wo züge zum entgleisen gebracht
werden gleise beschädigt und wo es
durchaus gewaltsame von formen des
widerstandes ja in den letzten wochen
gegeben hat also es gibt diese vier
möglichkeiten und für alle vier gibt es
gewisse argumente die ukraine halte ich
für die unwahrscheinlichste der
varianten aber derzeit kann man noch
nicht sagen was ist denn jetzt
tatsächlich war wir gehen auch gleich
noch mal mehr auf die einzelheiten ein
aber jetzt für alle die noch nicht so
viel über das thema wissen oder auch
jetzt erst dazu gekommen sind schauen
wir erst einmal gemeinsam in einen
beitrag was ist genau passiert von ralph
goldmann
zwei tage nach dem anschlag zeigt das
russische staatsfernsehen ein
kondolenzschreiben von präsident putin
er würdigte du ihn als patrioten
russlands sie war am samstagabend auf
einer hauptstraße in moskau durch die
explosion einer autobombe ums leben
gekommen die 29 jährige galt als
kremltreue journalistin sie hat er den
krieg in der ukraine offen unterstützt
wir können bestätigen sagt eine
sprecherin des ermittlungskomitees dass
der sprengsatz unter dem auto auf der
fahrerseite angebracht wurde daria
dubina saß am steuer und starb am tatort
russland macht die ukraine für den
anschlag verantwortlich die ukraine wies
das zurück auch der sicherheitsexperte
nico lange hält das für unwahrscheinlich
er gibt aus ukrainischer perspektive
keinen sinn sich mit frau norina zu
beschäftigen die hat im kreml nichts
entschieden die führt auch diesen krieg
nicht
dass der kreml in so kurzer zeit
erklärung hat es etwas dass er die sache
unglaubwürdig macht ein ehemaliger
russischer oppositionsabgeordneter
berichtete heute die sogenannte bisher
unbekannte nationale republikanische
armee stecke hinter dem anschlag
ist zum jetzigen zeitpunkt schwer zu
beurteilen ob das ein echtes bekenntnis
ist und ob es tatsächlich gewalttätigen
widerstand gibt in russland das wäre
bemerkenswert
möglicherweise galt das attentat aber
auch in julias vater alexander er gilt
als rechtsnationalistische ideologe
hatte die idee einer eurasischen union
unter russischer führung videos in den
sozialen netzwerken zeigen ihnen kurz
nach der tat am ort des anschlags
russlands feinde hätten seine tochter
gemein und heimtückisch umgebracht sagte
er
sprechen wir noch mal über die beiden
theorien die heute am meisten diskutiert
worden sind zum einen eben über den
russischen inlandsgeheimdienst der also
der ukraine die schuld gibt und vor
allem ganz gezielt einer ukrainerin
sie soll so sagt es russland ende juli
gemeinsam mit ihrer tochter nach
russland eingereist sein und jetzt nach
der tat nach estland geflohen sein was
ist ihre einschätzung zu so einer
erklärung worum geht es dabei genau
ja ich glaube dass die russischen
behörden natürlich unter öffentlichen
druck stehen nach so einem ereignis und
schnell eine lösung
präsentieren wollen und gleichzeitig ist
es aus russischer sicht eine einfache
und naheliegende erklärung zu sagen die
ukraine ist schuld ich halte das für
unglaubwürdig zum einen
sind die russischen sicherheitsbehörden
offenbar nicht dazu in der lage gewesen
so einen anschluss anschlag in einer
sehr sicheren gegend in moskau zu
verhindern wollen aber schon kurze zeit
danach alles genau wissen das halte ich
nicht für plausibel und
gleichzeitig muss man sich doch fragen
warum sollte eigentlich frau dubina
für die ukraine ein ziel sein die
ukraine haben erstens alle hände damit
voll zu tun ihr land zu verteidigen
und zweitens frau dubina spielt jetzt
nicht so eine wichtige rolle in diesem
krieg dass sie aus der ukrainischen
sicht ein ziel darstellen könnte sie ist
eine propagandistische sie hat zum
beispiel dazu aufgerufen die
kriegsgefangenen aus dem us auf stahl
stahlwerk in mariupol
hinrichten zu lassen
sie hat sehr radikale äußerungen gemacht
und ganz sicher gehört sie zu denjenigen
ideologen in russland die sagen die
ukraine hat kein recht darauf ein
eigenes volk zu sein aber sie ist kein
teil des machtapparats sie hat auch
keinen zugang zu putin
insofern erkenne ich nicht warum die
ukraine sich mit frau norina
beschäftigen sollte und dann gehen wir
noch mal auf das zweite heute viel
diskutierte thema ein da geht es um ein
bekenner statement also es geht um eine
gruppierung so und die soll sich bei
einem ehemaligen abgeordneten nicht nur
häufig also hat sich bei einem
ehemaligen abgeordneten der russischen
opposition bei japan ohno marinov
gemeldet der das muss man wissen lebt
seit einigen jahren in der ukraine so
und hat dort in einem fernsehinterview
eben von diesem bekenner statement
gesprochen von einer widerstandsgruppe
die bislang noch unbekannt war die jetzt
keiner zu diesem zeitpunkt bislang
kannte und diese widerstandsgruppe die
soll sich also zu dem anschlag bekannt
haben bevor wir mit ihnen darüber
sprechen können wir kurz noch mal in
dieses interview rein das haben wir auch
vorliegen in ein ausschnitt davon wovon
der dagegen spricht
dieser anschlag wie auch andere
partisanen angriffe der letzten monate
auf dem gebiet der russischen föderation
wurde durch die nationale
republikanische armee verraucht
über das portal als partisan auf dem die
wachsende welle des widerstands in
russland beleuchtet wird haben wir
verbindung zu ihren kämpfern auf
die kämpfer der enea haben mich
ermächtigt heute ihr manifest
vorzutragen
russische aktivisten militärangehörige
politiker und heute kämpfer der
nationalen republikanischen armee echten
kriegstreiber räuber und unterdrücker
der völker russlands
wir erklären den präsidenten russlands
zum supertor und kriegsverbrecher der
die verfassung verletzt und eine
bruderkrieg zwischen den slawischen
völkern entfesselt sowie russische
soldaten in den sicheren sinnlosen tod
geschickt hat
putin wird durch uns entmachtet und
vernichtet
wir erklären die geschäftsleute ihr geld
durch korruption und beziehungen zu den
machthabern verdienen zu verrätern und
handlangern des usurpator
alle russen auf sich uns anzuschließen
und die weiß blau weiße fahne des neuen
russlands zu wissen
kein feind russlands und russland ist
kein feind der menschheit und wir werden
das mit unseren taten beweisen
so da stellt sich natürlich jetzt fragen
zum einen wie realistisch ist es dass es
so eine gewaltbereite widerstandsgruppe
gibt die man jetzt zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt noch nicht kannte und auch
dass sie das einem ehemaligen
abgeordneten der jetzt in der ukraine
lebt überlassen das zu verkünden dass
ford zu lesen wie für wie realistisch
halten sie das also ich finde es
zunächst mal und das geht glaube ich
vielen so die sich schon länger mit
russland beschäftigen sehr überraschend
wir reden von einem land in dem seit
mittlerweile jahrzehnten die opposition
entweder tot ist im gefängnis sitzt oder
das land verlassen hat und hoya zuletzt
mit beginn dieses krieges die maßnahmen
gegen die opposition noch mal sehr stark
verschärft worden sind also ein land in
dem man verhaftet wird und bis zu 15
jahre ins gefängnis kommen kann wenn man
mit einem weißen blatt papier auf der
straße demonstriert also das ist schon
überraschend dass es jetzt eine solche
erklärung gibt und nach dieser erklärung
angeblich bewaffneten gewalttätigen
widerstand in russland und wenn man sich
den wortlaut genau ansieht dann sieht
man aber zumindest wo die verbindung
dieser erklärung zu herrn von orlow
bestehen könnte japan of war ja zuletzt
abgeordneter der kommunistischen partei
war so lange sehr lange bei den
russischen kommunisten er hat schon
verschiedene dinge in seinem leben getan
auch in der geschäftswelt aber er kommt
er aus einem
linken oder vielleicht sogar
linksradikalen hintergrund und wenn man
die formulierung die ist kampf zwischen
slawischen bruder völkern und auch die
kriegserklärung an geschäftsleute und
organischen kann man vermuten dass es da
auch ähnliche hintergründe gibt
zumindest bei den verfassern dieses
bekenntnis schreibens ob die tatsächlich
auch eine organisierte gruppe sind die
solche anschläge verüben kann das kann
man zum jetzigen zeitpunkt gar nicht
einschätzen was man aber sagen kann ist
dass es so eine erklärung gibt dass herr
porno mayotte diese erklärung vor trägt
das überhaupt diese anschlag
stattgefunden hat das zeigt doch dass
dieser krieg der krieg putins gegen die
ukraine nicht so läuft
wie gut sich das vorgestellt hat und
dass das zu entwicklungen führt die
vielleicht für uns schwer zu
durchschauen sind dabei ganz sicher auch
für putin schwierig sind haben dazu eine
frage aus dem chat von sepp 51 50 er
schreibt bei youtube wie groß oder klein
kann so eine widerstandsarmee sein oder
werden in russland und wir oder werden
in russland groß oder klein kann sie
sein oder werden und wie erfolgreich
kann so eine resistenz sein
das ist mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit so
dass wenn das widerstandsgruppen gibt in
russland dass es sich um kleine gruppen
handelt putin hat sein system der
unterdrückung und der kontrolle jetzt
seit mehr als 20 jahren sogar noch
länger ausgebaut geheimdienst polizei
sicherheitsbehörden kontrollieren ja
jeden aspekt des lebens und eben viele
menschen die sich als opposition zu
putin dargestellt haben die sich
kritisch geäußert haben sind entweder
außer landes oder im gefängnis oder
sogar tod also es sehr schwierig
widerstand zu organisieren
wir haben aber gesehen in den letzten
wochen und monaten seit diesem krieg
dass es immer wieder anschläge gegen
bahngleise dass züge entgleisten sind
das einberufung center der armee in
brand gesteckt worden sind also scheint
es vielleicht keine große organisation
aber ein netzwerk von leuten zu geben
die in irgendeiner form widerstand
leisten wollen und sie zumindest auch
zeigen wollen nicht alle russen
unterstützen diesen krieg es gibt auch
welche die dagegen stehen ich möchte
auch ein paar kommentare vorlesen aus
unserem stream und zwar einmal von der
wand demong er schreibt bei youtube
respekt an diesen widerstand sofern es
denn wirklich gibt eine andere sprache
versteht putin nicht wie man an den
verhaftungen et cetera gesehen hat und
captain nemo schreibt bei youtube es
wäre ja nicht der erste krimi mord wenn
der kreml dahinter stecken sollte wie
wahrscheinlich ist denn das mal zurück
gefragt dass der kreml in dem falle
gegen eine person die eine
sympathisantin des regimes es sich
richten würde würden sie das nochmal für
uns einschätzen man zunächst mal
kann man doch mal feststellen
es ist nicht ungewöhnlich dass russland
liegt russland rückständig vor diesen
krieg schon mit kriegsbeginn und auch
während dieses krieges insofern würde
ich jetzt den russischen aussagen und
den russischen meldungen keinen glauben
schenken
die
das attentat auf frau dubina
hat ja eine ganz breite wirkung
und es gab verschiedene fälle in der
russischen vergangenheit wo die
geheimdienste selbst operationen
vorgenommen haben wo es
vorgetäuschte taten gibt also dass sowas
dass man sowas nicht ausschließen kann
dass so etwas denkbar ist hat russland
in seiner geschichte gezeigt und hat
auch putin und seine geheimdienst clique
in der geschichte gezeigt was ich
interessant finde in dem zusammenhang
ist dass es für die organisation des
widerstands gegen putin möglicherweise
gar nicht entscheidend ist ob jetzt
bewiesen wird dass die widerstandsgruppe
diesen anschlag verübt hat die
interessante frage der nächsten tage und
wochen wird doch sein erhält dieser
widerstand der diese erklärung abgegeben
hat erhält der zuspruch gibt es leute
die auf die plattformen kommen gibt es
leute im telegramm kanälen und anderswo
die sagen ja wir wollen das unterstützen
wir stehen gegen diesen krieg und gehen
stehen gegen putin also da könnte unter
umständen sogar für putin eine gefahr
darin liegen dass durch die große
öffentlichkeit sich jetzt neue neuer
widerstand formiert wir können gleich
noch mal ein paar mehr fragen aus dem
stream mit ihnen klären ich möchte nur
ganz kurz auch noch mit einem kollegen
von uns sprechen der ist nämlich live in
der ukraine mit henna hebestreit und da
gibt es ja auch einige fragen die wir
haben hannah schön dass du heute abend
bei uns ist alles
stellt muss im norden sagt wie man im
norden sagt und jetzt bist du im osten
für uns nämlich live in der ukraine und
es stellt sich natürlich die frage wie
reagiert die ukraine auf die
anschuldigungen des russischen
geheimdienst von heute wann wie wird
darüber berichtet was hast du gelesen
gehört gesehen
also der ukrainische präsidentschaft
berater am sonntag wir haben da nichts
zu tun wir sind kein terror regime wir
machen so etwas nicht wir sind keine
bande von gaunern dass es eine
spezialität der russischen seite der
militärgeheimdienst sagte auch überhaupt
keinen kommentar darauf aber es würde
sich doch zeigen dass sich das russische
team von innen auflösen würde das sind 2
kommentare die ganz klar sagen die
ukraine will damit nichts zu tun haben
man hat hier auch so ein bisschen angst
wir haben jetzt den unabhängigkeitstag
am mittwoch der groß gefeiert wird und
da ist die sorge schon groß dass es
seitens der russen dass störaktionen
schweren beschuss oder dergleichen mehr
geben kann man hat hier auch schon
mehrere maßnahmen verhängt um die leute
auf der straße nicht in gefahr zu
bringen und wenn dann jetzt natürlich so
etwas kommt was man der ukraine in die
schuhe schieben möchte aus sichtweise
der ukraine dann weiß man natürlich
nicht ob das ein grund sein könnte für
die russen hier zu agieren raketen zu
schicken als vergeltungsschlag da ist
die sorge natürlich nicht ganz klein das
ist angesprochen am mittwoch ist nicht
nur ein halbes jahr lang schon krieg in
der ukraine sondern es ist auch der
unabhängigkeitstag hat man sich jetzt
noch einmal irgendwie anders dazu
positioniert wurde nochmal etwas mehr
abgesagt als vorher oder wird dieser tag
so oder so aufgrund des krieges dieses
jahr gar nicht begangen gar nicht
gefallen
also wir haben gestern abend in odessa
erlebt dass man das noch gefeiert hat
aber man hat auch ganz klar gesagt das
ist das letzte jetzigen diesem nächsten
drei tagen dann wird das erst wieder
groß feiern wenn der sieg über russland
so weit sei das ist natürlich sehr viel
auch ukrainische propaganda aber ist so
man hat wirklich sämtliche
veranstaltungen hier in kiew abgesagt
eisenbahn verbindungen wurden gestrichen
oder aufs nötigste
eingeschränkt in manchen städten wie zum
beispiel aktiv wurden ausgangssperren
für drei tage verhängt das zeigt es gibt
durchaus die sorge dass da in den
nächsten tagen etwas passieren könnte
und gibt es auch schon eine reaktion
jetzt ganz aktuell auf diese
anschuldigungen des geheimdienstes dass
es sich um eine ukrainerin gehandelt
haben soll die angeblich diesen anschlag
verübt haben soll in russland wurde sich
dazu auch schon konkret geäußert
es wurde ja seitens der russen gesagt
diese personen habe eine nähe zum azoff
regiment von dort gab es umgehend ein
dementi diese frau habe mit dem us
aufregend nichts zu tun habe auch dort
niemals gedient und wenn man sich hier
auf der straße unterhält er sagen die
leute das ist eine geschichte die hätte
sich schon eine karriere als als als
spionage autor nicht besser ausdenken
können warum soll denn eine person von
der man weiß dass sie es oft steht vom
russischen auslandsgeheimdienst im land
selber einfach nicht beobachtet worden
sein wie so hätte sie das alles tun
können das klingt alles in den ohren und
augen der ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
sehr sehr merkwürdig ich will ich sagen
räuberpistole aber
man schüttelt ja schon im kopf danke
anhänger hebestreit neu für uns in der
ukraine und am mittwoch wird er
natürlich auch für uns über den
unabhängigkeit dort vor ort berichten
über dem unabhängigkeitstag dankeschön
und
wir können jetzt noch einmal mit nico
lange sprechen es gab noch einige fragen
im stream nicht dazu gesehen habe
nämlich zum beispiel
hier von miss sunshine bei youtube die
sich auch fragt wie wahrscheinlich ist
denn ein racheakt von putin in der
ukraine wo denn die russen ja behaupten
es sei alles die schuld der ukraine wie
wahrscheinlich ist so was herr lange
ich glaube man muss nüchtern festhalten
putin hat mit diesem angriffskrieg viele
grausamkeiten verübt in der ukraine ist
jetzt nicht so dass man da nach
besondere vorwände brauchte um noch
etwas grausameres zu tun russland verübt
raketen anschläge bombardiert zivilisten
und hat schon viele kriegsverbrechen
verübt
ich glaube auch dass es ein mythos ist
zu denken russland kann jetzt unbegrenzt
weiter eskalieren man sieht ja dass die
russischen streitkräfte probleme haben
in der ukraine
aber das was die
ukrainerin ukraine befürchten dass
wieder raketen auf städte geschossen
werden auf wohnungen auf wohnhäuser wie
das in der vergangenheit in kiew
interaktiv in anderen städten schon
passiert ist dass es glaube ich leider
ein realistisches szenario nicht nur
wegen dieses anschlags sondern auch weil
der ukrainische unabhängigkeitstag so
ein wichtiges historisches datum ist und
weil putin ganz sicher frustriert ist
dass er sechs monate
nach dem beginn des krieges einen krieg
bei weitem nicht gewinnen konnte seine
ziele nicht erreichen konnte obwohl er
selbst glaube ich davon ausgegangen ist
dass es nicht mal sechs tage dauern
würde
ich sehe noch einige fragen zum ende
jetzt dieser sendungen die wir aber
gerne noch beantworten wollen zu dieser
möglichen gruppierung und auch nochmal
zu dem anschlag selbst zunächst die
frage von uwe jacobs bei youtube wie
sehr fürchtet putin die gruppen also
vielleicht solche widerstandsgruppen
macht ihm das sorge
ich denke putin macht grundsätzlich
alles sorgen was er nicht kontrollieren
kann er ist ein
geheimdienstler der mit zu andere mit
anderen geheimdienst menschen zusammen
regiert er ist jemand der aus
persönlicher erfahrung auch die
friedliche revolution in der ddr
miterlebt hat er bekanntermaßen in
dresden zu der zeit und seither an der
macht es sieht man ja dass er
systematisch versucht alles zu
unterdrücken alles zu kontrollieren
jeden widerstand im keim zu ersticken
deswegen sollte es wirklich eine
bewaffnete widerstandsgruppe eine
gewalttätige widerstandsgruppe geben
oder sollte diese bewegung die sich ross
partisanen nennt jetzt viele anhänger
bekommen ist das ganz sicher etwas dass
putin sorgen macht er hat kein sicheres
gefühl als präsident russlands das
unterschätzen wir hier in deutschland
manchmal aber wer ständig die wahlen
fälschen muss wer ein riesiges system
aus polizei und geheimdienst aufbauen
muss um die eigenen menschen zu
kontrollieren er fühlt sich ja nicht
sicher und fühlt sich ganz sicher jetzt
auch von dieser entwicklung bedroht
und zu der tat selbst fragt sich jetzt
bei youtube wie konnte das eigentlich
passieren also wie konnte die bombe
unter dem auto platziert werden muss man
nicht davon ausgehen dass gerade
bereiche mit vips dass da die bewachung
sehr streng ist und das war ja auch
nicht irgendwo es war ganz in der nähe
von moskau in einem ganz bekannten vor
ort also wie konnte so was überhaupt
passieren können sie sich da hinten rein
draus machen das ist eine sehr gute
frage eine berechtigte frage
dieses gebiet in der nähe von moskau
dieser vor ort mit der berühmten
rohbiogas straße wo putin selbst mit wwf
die russische staatsführung die
wirtschaftsbosse ihre häuser haben wir
auch ihre familien wohnen die ist
natürlich sehr gut bewacht nicht nur von
geheimdienst und polizei sondern die
wirtschaftsbosse haben wir oft noch
eigene sicherheitskräfte es gibt dort
überwachungskameras wird eine spannende
frage sein zu sehen waren die eigentlich
ausgeschaltet wer kann eigentlich
überwachungskameras ausschalten in so
einem land wie russland
also das ist schon wirklich eine
überraschung dass der anschlag an diesem
ort stattfindet und es ist eigentlich
kaum vorstellbar dass eine einzelne
person oder eine ganz kleine gruppierung
in der lage ist so ein anschlag an
diesem ort auszuführen
und bogotá tonnen möchte ich auch noch
auf herausgreifen hier bei youtube fragt
sich wie wahrscheinlich ist es dass es
nach nachahmer zu dieser tat geben wird
die
erklärung dieser gruppe die von dem
abgeordneten ehemaligen abgeordneten
verlesen worden ist scheint ja ein
bisschen darauf zu hoffen dass man durch
so eine erklärung und durch öffentliches
bekenntnis zu radikalen widerstand ich
meine das sind ja keine sanften
formulierungen dort solch ein
öffentliches bekenntnis leute dazu
ermutigen kann gewaltsamen widerstand zu
leisten
insofern werden glaube ich auch die
russischen sicherheitsbehörden jetzt
nicht nur in moskau sondern vor allen
dingen ja auch in allen regionen des
landes versuchen sehr genau darauf zu
achten ob da jetzt weitere entwicklungen
stattfinden
das statement lese ich auf jeden fall
als ermutigung für alle die widerstand
leisten wollen jetzt mehr zu tun und
denken sie dass mit dann auch dazu
führen dass jetzt putin selbst das
natürlich alle die der regierung nahe
stehen in russland jetzt künftig noch
mehr auf ihre sicherheit achten werden
dass ich künftig auch noch mehr in
russland verändern wird wegen eines
solchen anschlags also wir reden bei
putin jahr von jemandem der schon aus
angst vor einem virus sich zehn meter
von anderen weg setzt der schon seit
jahren da gibt es viele berichte darüber
kaum erreichbar ist selbst für seine
engsten mitstreiter der niemandem
vertraut der viel zeit in einem bunker
im ural zubringt und gar nicht in moskau
ist also ich glaube putin hat schon ein
sehr sehr sehr paranoides level erreicht
was seine eigene sicherheit betrifft
viele andere werden das auch tun es gibt
einen besonderen aspekt bei diesem
anschlag brodowiner ist die tochter von
herrn dougan insofern werden sich jetzt
glaube ich viele in der russischen
machtclique gedanken machen über ihre
familie wenn die anschläge auch in diese
richtung erzielen sollten aber es ist
tatsächlich so dass die russische elite
sich schon sehr abgeschottet hat und vor
allem dingen putin extrem auf seine
sicherheit aufpasst und niemanden an
sich heran lässt
danke für diese einschätzung für diese
antworten und ihre zeit heute abend nico
lange
und danke natürlich auch an euch für
eure zeit für eure fragen und für euere
anmerkungen
wir sind natürlich am mittwoch live für
euch wenn sich der krieg in der ukraine
jetzt sechs monate hinzieht und das auch
gleichzeitig der tag ist der
unabhängigkeit der ukraine da werden wir
wieder für euch berichten und bis dahin
sage ich danke und tschüss